le lavaux shackleton
à la fin de 1946 le coastal commandes de
la royal air force avaient été réduits à
une force de moins de 50 avions répartis
en 8 squadron accompagné d'une unité
météorologiques et de deux unités de
reconnaissance photographique à longue
distance le commandement et elysées
entre le groupe 18 dont les quartiers
généraux se trouvait en écosse et le
groupe 19 du devon ainsi qu'avec le
commandement d'irlande du nord et du
centre al photographique l'etablishment
de la base de benson
il
non
pascal la bourgeoisie
et
parmi ses missions la reconnaissance
météorologiques au dessus de
l'atlantique était considéré comme
d'importance majeure pour les prévisions
météo
les avions utilisés étaient des andes
les pages halifax vétérans de la
deuxième guerre mondiale
les escadrons de reconnaissance
photographique effectué des missions de
surveillance avec des spitfire des
mosquito aider lancaster les squadron
anti-sous-marins après que la rff est
rendu ses libérateurs aux usa en raison
des termes des contrats lend lease était
composé de sunderland et de lancaster
disposant pour la plupart d'équipement
datant de la guerre
tout ceci se dérouler dans une période
durant laquelle les soviétiques
s'engageaient dans un programme
d'extension massive de leurs forces sous
marines et de leur flotte de surface
il y avait donc un besoin urgent de
doter la rl d'un avion de reconnaissance
maritime moderne à long rayon d'action
le lincoln construit par adro était l'un
des prétendants pour le rôle
cet avion était très proche du lancaster
puisqu'il en était directement inspirés
cependant a contrario du lancaster ce ne
fut pas un avion couronnée de succès
le brillant ingénieur en chef d'avro
rail chadwick rouge tu as donc le
lincoln pour remplir ses missions
selon lui cet avion avait des lacunes en
termes de performances d'équipements et
de confort pour l'équipage indispensable
pour un avion devant tenir l'air pendant
de nombreuses heures à partir du lincoln
un nouvel appareil fut conçu qui allait
servir la rfm pendant 40 années
le havre aux 696 répondait à les
spécifications de l'air ministry r5 46
ce nouvel appareil bénéficiait de
nombreuses innovations propre rincon
comme le fuselage et son train
d'atterrissage et gardait un air de
ressemblance avec le lancaster non pas
j'étais différent passant d'une position
intermédiaire à une position haute avec
un agrandissement des surfaces
verticales
le nouveau fuselage étaient plus larges
plus haut et plus long que celui du
lincoln
il disposait de deux moteurs rolls royce
griffonne 57 de 2450 chevaux et de de
gryphon 56 tous les quatre équipes et
des lys dh
hydro matica cipal fait unique ses
hélices était contrarotatives une
première sur un avion quadrimoteur
le havre au 646 était aussi remarquable
parce qu'il était le plus gros avion
britannique de son époque
une foule de badauds s'étaient massés à
woods forte par la froide et humide
matinée du 9 mars 1949 pour voir jihad
jimmy aurel le chef pilote d'essai
d'avro faire décoller le prototype pour
la première fois
il ne pouvait imaginer que cet avion
serait toujours en première ligne avec
la ras
plus de quarante ans plus tard
le premier vol du prototype n'a duré que
33 minutes après lequel jimmy or elle
rapporta que l'avion volait très bien et
est aussi agréable que ses prédécesseurs
lancaster et lincoln
après quelques ajustements mineurs
l'avion effectuera un second vol de 45
minutes
au total trois prototypes furent
commandés et furtives matricule et vw
126 vw 131 et vw 135 et même avant que
le premier d'entre eux ne vole à vraux
avait reçu une commande de 29
exemplaires de série
sur recommandation de reuil shadwick
l'avion reçu le nom de shackleton
d'après le grand explorateur anglais
serait renaissent shackleton les
premiers avions de série serait donc
dénommé shackleton gr 1 malheureusement
ce grand ingénieur disparu tragiquement
lors du vol d'essai du prototype du
tudor 2 qui s'écrase à watford le 23
août 1947
il ne puis donc voir voler une autre de
ses créations
le havre au 968 le puissant vulkan
le 21 avril le premier prototype le vw
126 s'envola du aéroplan armement
expérimentaux l'établissment de bosses
comme dan pour débuter les essais
constructeur conduit par les pilotes
d'essais davroux épaulés par leurs
collègues des unités décès
le deuxième prototype fut terminée à
temps pour participer au salon
aéronautique de farnborough en 1949 où
il fut présenté en vol par le pilote
d'essai johnny baker le 12 février 1950
cet appareil rejoignez le premier
prototype à bosse comme dom et fut
envoyé l'année suivante au soudan pour
les essais par temps chaud
c'est lors de son vol retour qu'il subit
une collision avec un volatile qui
détruisit totalement son radôme donné en
perspective et qui endommagea le système
d'armes
un événement qui aura des effets sur les
versions ultérieures du shackleton le
premier et le deuxième prototype
disposait de nacelles contrôler à
distance qui emportait chacune un canon
de 20 mm et une tourelle de que
disposant de deux mitrailleuses calibre
12,7 mm mais dès les premiers essais en
vol à bosse comme dom elles furent
déposées
lorsque le troisième prototype levé w135
apparu pour son premier vol le 29 mars
1950 il était très proche du standard de
série et effectua ses vols de
développement à watford
avant de rejoindre bosse comme le 4
juillet 1950 pour les essais officiels
le besoin urgent de shackleton pour
remplacer les lancaster servant de
palliatifs dans le coastal commun
jusque-là oblige à accélérer la
production et finalement la première
machine de ses rivaux là pour la
première fois le 28 mars 1950 la veille
du premier vol du troisième prototype
les premiers shackleton entrèrent en
service ont février 1951 dans l'unité de
formation opérationnelle du coastal
commandes à kinloss en écosse et le
premier squadron le squadron 120
également stationnée à kinloss reçu ses
premiers avions le 30 mars 1951 pour
commencer la transition du lancaster au
nouvel appareil
les avions de la deuxième série sûrs
linas l extérieur élargi pour recevoir
le gryphon 57 à la place du 56 ha
deux nouvelles bases de shackleton
furent établies à 5 qui vole en
cornouailles et ballykelly en irlande du
nord tandis que d'autres unités furent
stationné à saint-lô gagnent halder gros
et gibraltar en plus de kinloss déjà
cité un certain nombre de problèmes
apparus au tout début de la carrière du
shackleton et une deuxième version de la
spécification r5 46 fût publié le 3
juillet 1950 à bron reçu la mission de
reconstruire le premier prototype pour
convenir à l'aérodynamique de la version
r2
sous cette nouvelle forme cette alliance
envola le 19 juillet 1951
les modifications consistait en un nez
complètement redessiné et allongé dans
lequel les versions ultérieures
remporterait deux canons de 20 mm et une
cabine avant façon mitrailleur de nay
la partie arrière du fuselage fut
allongé en une forme conique et un
radôme factice fut installé juste en
arrière de l'ale le train d'atterrissage
à vos jumelles fut montée et des
améliorations furent apportées au
système de freinage la roulette de que
reçu un système de verrouillage
alors que le travail de conversion
débutait sur le prototype aérodynamique
un des fuselages de m&a à fut prélevé
des chaînes d'assemblage est complété
comme prototype mr2 cet avion compléter
avec son armement et son radar anti sous
marins fit son premier vol le 17 juin
1952 et les essais officiels
commencèrent à bosse comme donne le mois
suivant le mr2 n'était pas considéré
comme un nouveau modèle et fut livrée
aux squadron à la suite de leur chat
culte aux originaux
le premier dmr deux entrées en service
avec le squadron 42 200 livres ou le 16
janvier 1952
mais l'unité découvrit que cette
nouvelle version était très différente
des avions précédent
à
il fut décidé de standardiser la flotte
en une seule version
cependant les rouages officiel de
décision était bien grippé et ce ne fut
pas avant 1954 que les changements sur
les avions débutèrent en 1954 5 squadron
volet sur chaque hulten mr1 ou mr1 à
numéro 120 206 de 120 240 et 296 et si
sûr mr2 37 38 42 200 4 224 et 228
bon
la première apparition en masse de
shackleton se produisit lorsque 18
avions volaient en formation serrée au
dessus de buckingham palace pour les
célébrations du couronnement de la reine
en juin 1953 le shackleton s'avérait un
excellent avion et les divers squadron a
été très occupée par les nombreux
exercices organisés par l'otan ainsi que
par de nombreux voyages un peu partout
dans le monde
et
l'avion pouvait être facilement
entretenue par ses équipages et beaucoup
de pièces de rechange être emmené à bord
grâce à son fuselage volumineux les
shackleton basé à gibraltar couvrait la
zone méditerranéenne et avait la
possibilité de se déployer rapidement en
extrême orient en cas de besoin un
certain nombre de mr2 était utilisé par
l'unité de développement des systèmes de
combat anti sous marins pour de nombreux
essais dont celui de l'installation
d'une perche de détection magnétique
dans la queue de l'appareil
d'autres essais portèrent sur l'emport
de l'heure et de lancement d'armes dont
certains furent couronnés de succès
tandis que d'autres échoué
le choc disposait de nombreux systèmes
anti sous marins principalement le radar
est née chéri il est entré en service
avec le radar il reçu plus tard un truc
nommé au tholy cus qui était un
détecteur de gaz d'échappement autour
d'un exact
l'idée était de voler à très basse
altitude au-dessus de l'océan et pas en
fonction des conditions météo et de
détecter le monoxyde de carbone qui
s'échappait d'un sous-marin en plongée
ou schnorchel et vous pouviez en déduire
alors que la menace était celle d'un
sous marins conventionnels n'est pas
d'un sous marin nucléaire car les sous
marins nucléaires n'émettent aucune
trace de monoxyde de carbone campus le
shackleton dispose d'un système de
bouées acoustiques sous marine qui sont
largués selon un schéma tactique a
célébré sa cible sont supposés recevoir
leçon émanant du sous-marin en plongée
les boues activées met un bruit
acoustique et perçoivent les cours de ce
sont sur le sous-marin
il était de localiser le submersible et
de procéder ensuite à l'attack
l'installation d'un radeau de survie
aéroportée pour les missions de secours
en mer fut aussi étudié et un mr2 équipé
d'un radeau de survie sarraut mk iii fut
présent au salon de farnborough 2950
points
cependant l'équipement lyndon emportées
dans la soute armement lui fut préféré
et le radeau de survie ne fut jamais
utilisé opérationnellement
il y avait un certain nombre de mk2
modifié c'est qu'un le radeau de survie
n'entrait pas directement dans la soute
a bomb bomb doses étaient trop grands et
des il a fallu modifier les portes de la
soute
si on crée pas trop de traîner lorsqu'on
transportait le radeau de survie
aéroportée mais il fut abandonné vers
1954-55 au profit des équipements
lindholm l'art qui était à la base un
dinghy multiplace gonflables au contact
de la surface de l'eau un disposant de
deux conteneurs de nourriture et d'eau
tous réunis par quelques dizaines de
mètres de corps à ces trois complaire
pouvait être installés dans la soute à
bondues shackleton et être largué à une
altitude de 140 pieds et à une vitesse
de 140 9 avec un peu d'entraînement afin
de s'assurer qu'aucun des naufragés ne
puisse être touchés au moment du largage
jeu stérile entre temps où elle avait
pour acheter au début des années 50
nous sommes intéressés à d'autres
utilisations faire autre chose avec cet
avion est le mk iii fut développée à
partir de ces réflexions
ce n'est pas là et rêve qui conduisit au
mk iii il était le résultat d'un intérêt
des sud africains
souvient de joe rimington de moi même
ainsi que d'autres membres de la
compagnie à l'hôtel midland avec l'armée
de l'air sud africaine faisant les
premiers croquis du mk iii à l'arrière
des menus du restaurant c'est souvent la
manière dont la plupart des avions sont
conçus les meilleurs dessins et en plus
tu as repris par les bureaux d'études
au port
pourquoi
on
non
la longueur des vols dépend des de la
mission de nations
les sorties opérationnelles à longue
distance dans les premiers temps pouvait
durer parfois de 15 à 18 heures quand le
mk iii entrée en service il ya eu une
démonstration affronte bord au début des
années soixante quatre oies qui
décollera vers 15 heures des restes en
l'air 24 heures en mission autour du
golfe de gascogne 20 à 15 heures le
lendemain dans l'espoir d'impressionner
les clients potentiels et de décrocher
des ventes à l'export généralement cela
durée moyenne d'une mission maritime
était plutôt de l'ordre de 8 à 9 heures
quand nous sommes passés aux missions
d'alert aéroportée airborne warning
la durée moyenne était sans doute un peu
plus courte cette heure environ
généralement liés à la disponibilité des
chasseurs avec lesquels on s'exerçait la
durée maximale comme je les dis était de
24 heures pour le mk iii 18 pour les
premiers m cad non modifiées mais en
mission d' alerte aéroportée la plus
longue mission que nous avons fait était
quelque chose comme 13h45 je crois ce
fut mon vol le plus long sur shackleton
à double sens termes de distance la
vitesse de croisière était de l'ordre de
150 à 160 ne donc on pouvait couvrir
quelque chose comme 3200 kilomètres la
distance de convoyage était juste un peu
plus élevé
surprise
faire
moi je suis français
c'est sûrement vrai
m
dans un sens plus fort
là ça va être quelque chose
m
progrès
faire
pendant la période 1955 1956 toutes les
tourelles dorsale furent enlevés pour
donner un peu plus de place aux
équipages pour l'emport d'équipement
les équipes d'ingénieurs d'avro
ashburton donc continuer à rechercher
comment améliorer le shackleton et ses
performances
en 1954 ils ont commencé à travailler
sur la version mr3 un train
d'atterrissage tricycle fut installé
pour améliorer la tolérance de l'avion
au vent de travers au roulage est la
conséquence fut le raccourcissement de
la soute armement afin de laisser la
place au compartiment du train avant un
nouveau cockpit avec des panneaux de
vision latéral fut installé et on lui
ajoute à des réservoirs de carburant en
bout d'aile ces modifications
augmentèrent la masse maximale au
décollage de l'avion mais le carburant
supplémentaire lui donne est une
autonomie supérieure à 24 heures tandis
que le confort de l'équipage étaient
nettement améliorée
le prototype du shackleton mr3 valable
pour la première fois depuis woodford le
2 septembre 1955
malheureusement sa maniabilité était
insatisfaisante en particulier le
décrochage qui posait beaucoup de
problèmes
lorsque le mk iii est sortie c'était un
avion vraiment différent je suppose
qu'il était toujours appelé shackleton
pour éviter les objections du parlement
pour la construction de nouveaux avions
est l'hôte prévient qu'il ressemble à
beaucoup aux chacals tonnes il était
bien différent en terme de sections de
fuselage a new longueur d'envergure et
bien sûr sont elles étaient toutes
nouvelles utilisé par le mk iii était la
même que celle de l'âme strong world
anosy la différence principale était la
roulette de nez et les freins
hydrauliques soutien du coup nous avions
résolu les soucis de l'atterrissage d'un
quadrimoteur à roulettes de queue et et
surtout réussi à contrôler l'engin au
sol air aux données donne une bien
meilleure stabilité au sol je pense que
les freins hydrauliques sont plus
satisfaisant que les freins pneumatiques
mk3 comporter son lot d'innovations
comme le mac s'arrête sur les freins du
train principal le contrôle de la
roulette de nez sans parler de la
meilleure visibilité donc un grand
nombre de problèmes ont été résolus
eh ouais
l'arrivée du nimrod en service le 1er
octobre 1969 et ses livraisons aux
escadrons étaient le commencement de la
fin pour les shackleton mr3
c'est un bon
par exemple
je vais voir
oui
les choses
jamais
gk
la botte
rigole
jean paul
charles taylor
je
la question qui se pose est pourquoi
l'air force n'a pas modifié ses mk3 en
avion radar plutôt que les mk2 la
réponse est que quand le shackleton
entrer en service dans la greffe en tant
qu'avion d' alerte il ne devait être
opérationnel que pour quatre ans avant
que ne soit acheté un tout nouvel
appareil appelé à remplir cette mission
et bien sûr ça ne s'est pas passé du
tout comme cela alors que nous pensions
à une carrière initiale de quatre ans
les et plus économique de convertir des
mk2 qui avait subi un récent chantier
d'entretien que de convertir des mk iii
qui n'avait pas été modifié et qui
nécessiteraient une mise à jour plus
important pour être converti à la plus
économique de convertir les mk2 plutôt
que les mk iii
c'est ce sont donc les mk2 qui furent
transformés qui sont restés en service
dix neuf ans et demi comme un avion
radar ils ont subi deux chantiers de
rénovation pendant cette période
les divers problèmes rencontrés sur les
mr3 puis ensuite résolu avec le premier
exemplaire entre est un service aux 220e
squadron à ce niveau le 30 août 1957 4
squadron reçurent des shackleton mer 3
entre 1958 et 1959 numéro 120 210 203 et
206 et c'est pendant cette période que
fut programmes et l'amélioration de
l'avion en trois phases
phase 1 mise en service du radar as v 32
et de divers changements d'avionique
premier avion en service en juin 1959
les modifications de la phase iii
comprenait une reconstruction de la
structure du mr3 car l'ajout de nombreux
équipements avaient augmenté la masse de
l'avion et en pénaliser les performances
le shackleton mr2 survécu à cette
dernière version
il fut l'avion choisi en 1971 pour
répondre aux besoins britannique d'un
avion d' alerte avancée destinée à
contrer les intrusions dans l'espace
aérien du royaume uni
douze avions furent converti en
shackleton à w2a woodford le 30
septembre 1971
les changements sur l'avion comporte l
ajout d'un radar à l aps 20 montées dans
un radôme ventrale adopté du ferret
gannett w3 est une mise à jour complète
d équipements embarqués
le shackleton était assez difficile à
piloter
particulièrement pour un gars fort mais
sur des avions plus modernes
le plus délicat est l atterrissage
si vous n'aviez aucune expérience du
train classique
c'était un choc d'arriver sur chaque
elton est d'essayer de poser cet
imposant avions trois points avec cet
énorme menée dans votre champ de vision
et en plus par vent de travers d'un
point de vue de pilote si vous aviez
compris comment le poser le reste était
facile on avait de la chance sur le
contrôle en lacets dans le car nous
avions le double de capacité sur le
palonnier nécessaire même si on perdait
2 moteurs du même côté et donc pas de
soucis pour contrôler l'avion dans ses
marges de vitesse ils sont en effet bien
différente de celle des jets moderne
l'avion était assez lourd en profondeur
et aux ailerons et en fait pour faire
virer cet avion il fallait mettre
beaucoup de pieds en plus des ailerons
encore une fois c'est une technique
assez ancienne et n'auront plus
nécessaire sur les avions modernes
obama promettant pas pilote je ne peux
pas vraiment vous dire comment ça se
manier mais j'en ai entendu parler en
différents termes comme la reine du ciel
le cochon volant ce pas de contrôle en
dessous de 50 pieds en finale mais je
pense en général que c'était un avion
qui ne pardonnait pas ce qui a été
démontré dans un certain nombre
d'occasions mais qui était en fait
associé un problème mécanique majeur
notamment de moteur je pense qu'il était
bien mené par les pilotes ne faisait pas
souvent d'erreurs mais je pense aussi
que quelquefois ils ont oublié qu'il ne
fallait pas en faire
en 1964 les squadron de shackleton mr2
on transportait plus de 3500 bombe pour
soutenir le gouvernement d'athènes dans
son combat contre les forces rebelles
dans ces combats les forces d'attac
principal était constitué de rockers
enter du squadron 8
et il est assez ironique que ce squadron
furent formés à kinloss le 1er janvier
1972 pour être équipés de shackleton e
w2 le squadron déménagea à l'oci mousse
le 14 août 1973
le squadron 8 rempli son rôle
admirablement avec ses avions affecté au
quick reaction à leers pour empêcher
toute intrusion d'avion et nuit dans
l'espace aérien britannique
je
le shackleton sur le contrôle des
intercepteurs de la ras
les guidant vers les cibles et les
escortant jusqu'à la sortie
le shackleton a volé pour la première
fois en 1949 et bien sûr pendant les
années 80 et 90 il était considéré comme
une véritable pièce de musée en fait je
me souviens qu'en allant aux usa avec un
chat culte en 1986 on nous a demandé
vers quel musée nous étions en train de
convoyer notre avion dans ce continent
il faut garder à l'esprit que le premier
était arrivé en 1949 et que le dernier à
quitter le service en 1991 encore des
shackleton en état de vol
encore un qui volent et en termes de
comparaison avec les avions modernes
ces systèmes sont ceux des années 30
matches est le premier manchester vol a
certainement oui
il était considéré comme déjà démodé
mais il fascinait ceux qui le
regardaient et encore plus ceux qui
volent et dessus comment on conduit une
voiture de collection
la bentley de 1926 et difficiles à
comparer à une ferrari d'aujourd'hui et
la ferrari d'aujourd'hui disposent de
tout le confort moderne comme l'air
conditionné et des essuie-glaces
efficace à haute vitesse alors que les
voitures des années 20 ne disposait pas
d'un tel luxe
il en est de même avec le shackleton sa
principale différence et son concept
même in time
nous sommes aujourd'hui à l'ère des
commandes de vol numérique ch à la place
d'un bon gros câble qui traverse tout
l'avion jusqu'au surface de contrôle
cédric le concept est donc totalement
différent c'est presque du pilotage par
ordinateur
le chacal tonnes lui est menée par son
pilote et personne d'autre ne peut
contrôler ce que l'avion fait c'est un
avion pour pilotes par opposition un
avion ordinateur et de ce point de vue
je crois qu'il était intéressant à
piloter
selon leur origine maritime
les avions du squadron 8 effectué de
nombreuses missions et jusqu'à l'arrivée
des nouveaux 1/3 des awacs les sentries
sentinelle les derniers shackleton ont
continué ses missions jusqu'en 1991
les shackleton ont été engagés dans de
nombreuses missions très différente de
la lutte anti sous marins à la recherche
et au sauvetage à la reconnaissance
maritime en passant par la police
coloniale le soutien aux bombardiers le
transport de troupes mais aussi l'alerté
radar avancé et d'autres trop nombreuses
pour être mentionné
la mise en sommeil le huitième squadron
fut une triste journée
tout le monde savait que ça devait
arriver mais c'était une seule journée
puisque c'était leur dernier jour au
service de la rfa en particulier pour
ceux qui avait fait d'importants efforts
pour persuader ceux qui en avaient le
pouvoir de conserver un shackleton en
état de vol même comme avion
d'entraînement pour le battle of britain
memorial clyde il était décidé à ce que
je pense être une erreur de ne pas
préserver d'avion en état je suis
absolument heureux de savoir qu'il
existe quatre shackleton entre des mains
privées et pouvant être remis en état de
vol
allende 2 dans ce pays et de à chypre et
un de ces derniers a volé depuis qu'il
est entre des mains privées après avoir
été retirée du service
une des choses que nous faisons trop mal
dans notre aviation militaire et de
conserver nos avions historiques des
années avant qu'on soit capable de
ressusciter un halifax de la seconde
guerre mondiale pour avoir des avions
qui ont vraiment pris part à la guerre
victor which we les empreintes henry oui
c'était une triste journée pour le 8ème
squadron lorsqu'il a perdu ses
shackleton mais la tristesse était
tempéré par la réception des 2/3 des
sentries qui sont les plus modernes et
les plus avancés de tous les avions
radars volant à l'heure actuelle c'était
évidemment une bonne nouvelle pour
l'escadron mais il y avait quand même
beaucoup de tristesse en raison du
départ des shackleton pour lesquels
beaucoup avait de l'affection encore des
inconsolables de son départ de l'air
force
oui car ce qui est pas nous croisons
juste les doigts pour que ceux qui ont
acquis ces avions pour un usage civil
soit capable de les maintenir en état de
vol et qu'il reçoive toute la
coopération des autorités concernées
toutes ces missions avaient été
effectués avec un avion très efficace et
des équipages très professionnel
je ne veux pas dire que c'était un
mauvais jour lorsque le shaq a été
retiré du service d'un point de vue
opérationnel
car il était remplacé par un avion bien
plus performant le boeing sentries mk1
cependant c'était un jour plein de
nostalgie un paquet de gars avaient
passé des heures et des heures à bord du
shaq elton et beaucoup avaient de grands
souvenirs vécus à bord de ce vieil avion
il ne fallait pas sans tristesse que
nous les avons vus s'en aller
les équipages pouvaient bien se plaindre
du bruit et du manque de confort du chac
mais parmi ceux ci peut n'auront pas de
frissons en entendant le son unique de
ces vieux grognon deux moteurs un son
qui fait partie de nous pour longtemps
lorsque le shaq a volé pour la dernière
fois il y a eu quelques larmes
mais pour moi c'est arrivé un an trop
tard
si nous avions eu cet avion en service
le sentries et un an plus tôt ou bien
même des nimrod et bien le crash du shaq
sur l'île de harris n'aurait pas eu lieu
et nous aurions eu dix gars de plus avec
nous et nous n'aurions pas eu cet
horrible souvenirs m'ont pensons que
nous avions gardé le shackleton une
année trop